[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec charles blé goudé le
président du congrès panafricain pour la
justice et l'égalité des peuples le
cojep ancien leader des jeunes patriotes
et proche de l'ancien président ivoirien
laurent gbagbo avec lui nous allons
parler évoqué la présidentielle en côte
d'ivoire
bonjour charles blé goudé c'est votre
deuxième intervention dans la grande
interview sur arte france merci à vous
merci madame pas mal d'être invité la
deuxième fois et puis je suis heureux
alors pas de prise de position française
contre le troisième mandat que brigue
alassane ouattara l'actuel président
pourtant il ya une rencontre le 4
septembre entre le président français
emmanuel macron et son homologue
ivoirien
quelle est votre réaction
oh écoutez madame je pense que la france
et la côte d'ivoire entretiennent des
relations rien il est plusieurs années
certainement que les deux chefs d'état
en nous faire le point de ces relations
d'autant plus que quand vous observez
très bien que aujourd'hui le mali n'est
pas stable le continent ne l'est pas non
plus quant à se souvenir que dans le
sahel et règne encore de groupe deya
liste
apparemment le seul pays sur lequel la
force internationale peut encore
s'appuyer
ophrenie l'avancée du yayisme à cette
région de notre continent
c'est certainement la côte d'ivoire ce
sujet ont dû être à l'origine j'imagine
en ce qui concernant le troisième mandat
que le ministre a décidé de briguer je
crois que tout cela fait partie des
discussions diplomatiques
moi je fais la différence entre un
communiqué final quant à une rencontre
d'un tel sommet a lieu
il fait donc la différence entre un
communiqué final est un compte rendu
détaillé ne seront pas pressé dans tous
les cas je ne
pas qu'il appartient à la france dé
régler des problèmes entre ivoiriens
on ne peut pas vouloir une chose et son
contraire à la fois voilà ma position
donc je ne désespère pas je pense que la
sagesse finira par gagner les ivoiriens
eux mêmes on comprendre que notre pays a
plus que jamais besoin d'unité
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire par face à
toulouse jouer un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire nonda l'élection
passée la france installé le tournoi
c'est un secret de polichinelle et je ne
crois pas que la france est déployé tous
ses moyens
mais ces moyens militaires ces moyens
diplomatiques
c'est moins de lobbying pour donner à la
côte d'ivoire une dictature comme celle
à laquelle nous assistons aujourd'hui je
pense que la classe politique française
interdit serrage unis lachance aime la
côte d'ivoire et je pense d'eux et faire
en sorte que la côte d'ivoire ne soit
pas au rez-de-chaussée l'humanité savez
vous que le camp d'alassane ouattara met
en garde contre une certaine rhétorique
un discours xénophobe d'une certaine
opposition qui convienne justement à les
liens entre le président ivoirien et la
france aubay écoutez madame les
ivoiriens ont le regard aussi c'est vrai
ton univers la france pour que la côte
d'ivoire elle aussi se vivre sous l'ère
de la démocratie telle que cela se fait
en france tu penses que c'est ainsi
qu'il faut concevoir et interpréter la
position de l'opposition ivoirienne qui
ne comprend pas l'entêtement du chef de
l'état actuel de vouloir tordre le cou à
nos textes de vouloir céder dit lui même
est désacralisé la parole présidentielle
dit oui le matin et non le soir là quoi
doit on ne sait plus à quel saint se
vouer
la france est un partenaire historique
important c'est pourquoi il faut
comprendre les propos de l'opposition
ivoirienne qui souhaite simplement que
les partenaires la côte d'ivoire
les amis de la coi
il vire au secours de ce pays qui
finalement a déjà ses premiers mois déjà
ce a perdu deux blessés quand déjà
ça permet plus honni politiques et
électoraux voyez-vous appel que charles
blé goudé on ne comprend pas bien
finalement la position de l'opposition
que doit faire la france sait ce qu'elle
doit intervenir se positionner condamné
les violences s'opposer aux au troisième
mandat d'alassane ouattara vous me
demandez ce que doit fait la france la
france
je pense que elle sait ce qu'elle a à
faire
la france à installer le président
alassane ouattara au pouvoir en 2000
ange pour la démocratie aujourd'hui le
bénin ouattara et son régime sont intel
débris mais le peuple
d'un côté on a des partisans de ouattara
qui marche visiblement qui peuvent même
violi les mesures de distanciation
social du rock au greek 19 qui peuvent
remplir des stades et de l'autre côté
bree mais des opposants qui lorsqu'ils
descendent dans la rue son lancement
brimés par les forces de l'ordre
le aussi par des milices harry
l'opposition ivoirienne attendant que la
france
quelle est la même force que la vie en
2011 voit interpellé le régime actuel
c'est ainsi que non sur la vidéo de
comprendre mais que tous ceux qui
veulent que la côte d'ivoire soit un
pays est un pays qui aime locomotive un
acteur de l'ouest donne aussi aider ce
pays à sortir de l'ornière
est-ce que vous condamnez les discours
xénophobes auxquelles font allusion
les autorités peut-être qu'on n'a pas la
mesurer mais dire que le président
ouattara n'a pas le droit de briguer un
troisième mandat n'est en rien une forme
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec 18
trous je ne faut pas si jamais vous
étaient tenus ici il s'agit de donner à
la côte d'ivoire des institutions
crédibles
ici il s'agit de respecter la
constitution de la côte d'ivoire ici il
s'agit de faire en sorte qu'on ait des
élections apaisées
ici il s'agit d'une femme a peur la
démocratie ici madame il s'agit de les
avoir peur des données on y voit des
règles c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
ici il s'agit de faire en sorte que les
lois soient des lois qu'un personnel je
suis pas des lois contre les opposants
et de loi pau le régime en place
voilà de quoi il s'agit mais vous êtes
un pro champ de l'ancien président
laurent gbagbo
savez vous comment il a accueilli le
dépôt de sa candidature par ses
partisans à abidjan
mais écoutez je vois que son avocat
s'est largement exprimé sur ce sujet et
puis même moi mais j'ai aussi appelé les
partisans à l'accompagner
la candidature de laurent gbagbo que je
considère comme mon manteau est atteinte
et leaders politiques j'ai toujours dit
que nous avons un rôle important à jouer
en côte d'ivoire qu'on soit dans cette
situation difficile en acadie les que
ses partisans se mobilisent comme on l'a
vu vraiment de manière massive pour
déposer sa candidature
ce qui veut dire qu'une plante doit pour
continue de susciter l'espoir en côte
d'ivoire parce que en définitive est
leader sa capacité à susciter l'espoir
et à faire en sorte de faire de donner
un bien-être et mieux-être à son peuple
ce qui définit un leader dans laurent
gbabo dix ans après continue de susciter
de l'espoir il susurre qui le prend
parce que je le connais et moi aussi je
suis content que cela ait eu lieu il
vous l'a confié vous de la confirmer à
parce qu'il ne s'est pas prononcé
sur sa candidature ce sont ses partisans
en côte d'ivoire qui ont déposé le
dossier à sa place il ya des silences
qui parle dans ce silence put
assouplissement merci et votre retour en
côte d'ivoire celui aussi de laurent
gbagbo est ce que ces retours sont
proches au si et seulement si cela
dépend des démos madame n'importe quel
citoyen dans le monde entier dans la
situation aimerait bien retrouver racing
rentrer chez lui au pays moi par exemple
j'ai bien envie d'aller s'incliner sur
la tombe des mains différents parents
que je peux laisser du temps mais mon
père que j'ai pas pu enterrer
hélas cela n'était pas malheureusement
pas de moi le plus humblement nous
sommes ivoiriens le repos n'est pas
belge je suis pas hollandais ne sont pas
détruits nous sommes venus ici pour des
faits que tout le monde connaît et je
pense qu'il faut savoir tourner cette
page là n'est pas instrumentaliser la
justice la propriété nationale nous a
emmenés dans cette ville a estimé que
non retourner chez eux je lance cet
appel à tous les partenaires de la côte
d'ivoire de faire en sorte que nous les
tâches ne faut pas instrumentaliser la
justice du genre ble goude a été
condamné à 20 ans gbagbo aussi donc
illégaux par eni et puis ensuite on
arrivait à la radiation du nom sur la
liste électorale ce cycle infernal de ce
petit jeu là il faut l'arrêter
et puis redonner à la côte d'ivoire la
paix mérite de rassembler de nouveau les
héroïnes sont les demandes de passeports
sur les demandes de passeport où en
êtes-vous apparemment selon les
autorités ivoiriennes cela concerne le
cas de laurent gbagbo il n'aurait pas
formulé de requête pour l'obtention d'un
passeport diplomatique est ce que vous
confirmez ce point et dites-nous par
ailleurs ou est-ce que vous en êtes dans
les procédures en ce qui me concerne je
n'ai jamais entrepris des démarches des
demandes ni des démarches obtenir et
quelques passeports que ce soit je
considère que le 22 mars de l'an 2014
j'ai été pris alors d'abidjan côte
d'ivoire crise votre bois ni embarquer
dans un avion vers des progiciels
f sans visa je suppose que le même
procédé qui a eu lieu à la lie pu avoir
lieu le tout donc quand je suis comme un
paquet qui attendent qu'on le dépose
alors on l'a pris voilà comment je me
considère c'est pourquoi je n'ai temple
n'entend pas mini une quelconque
démarche en ce qui concerne le président
gbagbo
ses paroles et ses avocats sont
largement exprimé sur ce sujet le clan
gbagbo s'est rendu à l'ambassade et côte
d'ivoire en belgique pour se voir
délivrer un passeport ordinaire
les autorités y voir et m'ont dit que ce
traitement est en cours c'est tout de
même curieux que pour nos touristes et
de ce genre parce que ils ceux qui ont
fait des demandes même après le
président gbagbo ont déjà obtenu leur
passeport
écoutez nul n'est dupe tout cela rend
d'un agenda politique pour lequel
deviendra vraiment nous sommes ici voilà
pourquoi je pense que il faut demander
au régime ivoirien différents sortes d
n'est pas crisper davantage les
positions la tension est déjà trop lourd
faute de crisper un moment donné faut
savoir arrêter le temps pose à tout cela
et puis essayons d'ouvrir le jeu
politique
n'ayez pas peur de la compétition loyale
position la cpi va quitter comme laurent
gbagbo mais la procureur fatou bensouda
a fait appel de la décision est ce que
vous êtes confiant pour la décision
finale
mes avocats vont cesser ces sujets et
dans tous les cas c'est un homme a
quitté qui nous parle en ce moment c'est
un moment à contre-pied aucune mesure
direction et pèse 90 il parle maintenant
et qui attend que le président ivoirien
permettent que nous puissions rentrer
chez nous tels que le groenland labo a
permis que lui rentre chez lui le en
novembre 2000 à un tel que le prof au
boni a permis que le plan de la boîte
chez lui à 1 1988
c'est de cette même manière
qu'aujourd'hui nous attendons que cette
tradition ne soient respectés et puis
que la compétition ait lieu que la
confrontation d idées l ie que nous
puissions devant les ivoiriens programme
contre programme proposé c'est comme
quand on fait le point
mais on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
de manière
na de manière continue nathalie des on
va marquer une courte pause et sont
retrouvés dans un instant pour la suite
de cette grande interview retour dans la
grande interview nous sommes avec
charles blé goudé le président du
congrès panafricain pour la justice et
l'égalité des peuples
ancien leader des jeunes patriotes
proches de l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo charles blé goudé on évoquait
l'instant la procédure à la cpi vous
savez que les états unis ont imposé à
fatou bensouda des sanctions économiques
inédites
elle est maintenant sur leur liste noire
est ce que vous considérez que cette
décision elle peut jouer en votre faveur
non madame leclerc dawim nous sommes ici
au des faits précis qui nous ont été
reprochés au cfl après plusieurs années
de procédure
là nous allons été acquitté libéré sous
conditions et un an plus tard ce cas le
28 mai 2020 nous sont considérés comme
des gens 30 qu' aucune mesure et
paisible ville que la chambre d'appel à
lever ces mesures et à 10g site que nous
pouvons nous déplacer dans tous les pays
signataires du traité de rome dont la
côte d'ivoire est je crois que la phrase
dont la côte d'ivoire n'a pas été
ajoutée au texte de manière occulte
voilà c'est dit militaire ou le reste je
n'oublie pas du tout et je ne voudrais
pas fondées de faux espoirs les faits
pour lequel nous avons été conduite y
est
nous on a quitté et puis nous attendons
d entre vous souhaitez rentrer en côte
d'ivoire et répondre le cas échéant
à la justice ivoirienne qui a entamé des
procédures à vendre à votre encontre
oui madame moi je si j'ai affronté la
justice internationale avec mes avocats
genevois eux
j'ai un problème avec la justice de chez
moi j'ai simplement premier relais
rentrer chez moi et puis je rentrais
chez moi à la maison
voilà c'est pour ces mêmes faits là que
je suis venu ici je suis venu ici pour
défaire post électoraux pour ce faire
j'ai été acquitté
aucune mesure ne pèse maintenant contre
moi moi je vais rentrer simplement chez
moi d'ailleurs je ne suis pas candidat
aux élections qui arrivent bien qu elle
m'intéresse mais qui m'intéresse parce
qu'il s'agit de l'avenir de mon pays
voilà je rentre chez moi je suis pas au
nom des jeux suivants alors vous n'êtes
pas candidat pour le scrutin du 31
octobre vous avez été radiés des listes
électorales comme l'ancien chef rebelle
guillaume soro
laurent gbagbo également sa candidature
elle a été déposé je le redis par ses
partisans à abidjan il ya très peu de
chance finalement que sa candidature
soit retenue par le conseil
constitutionnel qui doit se prononcer à
défaut de laurent gbagbo qui soutiendrez
vous est ce que ce sera le candidat d'
illégale du f pays le parti laurent
gbagbo pascal affi n'guessan ou alors
henri konon bédié l'ancien président
candidat lui du pdc hills
l'inde a beau avoir des fêtes et un
mariage il faut le célébrer il faut le
célébrer c'est qui ce moment ce n'est
pas tant de soutenir tel ou tel candidat
je constate simplement que la côte
d'ivoire commence à compter ses premiers
morts ces premiers blessés
cette première des places pré électoraux
c'est à dire que juste avant les
élections
la tension a commencé qu est le vif
notre pays ressemble aujourd'hui à une
poudrière qui atteint d'exploser le but
c'est fait et n'attend que la flamme
c'est qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
réunies les ivan autour d'une table et
discuter des sujets même le plus fâché
pourra peser la menace fait électorat
autre que celui qui gagne gagnera dans
la paix et pour l'instant gouverner dans
la paix telle est ma démarche
aujourd'hui et s'assurera que mon
équipement nous allons nous ne
travaillons pas soutenir tel ou tel
candidat
il faut pas conduit la côte d'ivoire
droit dans le mur ma position est celle
de mon lit et qu'il faudrait porter ces
élections ni leurs demandaient un report
du scrutin prévu le 31 octobre
solennellement selon m
je saisis cette occasion dit oh mon anti
aux amis de la côte d'ivoire aux
partenaires de la côte d'ivoire au
président alassane ouattara qu'il faut
reporter ces scrutins électoraux mais
tire pas profit pour convoquer des
assises nationales cela soit les filles
et fils de la coi devant autour d'une
table posée les problèmes le plus fâché
afin que celui qui gagne ganda la paix
tu gouvernes dans la paix blé goudé quel
que soit le candidat si un second tour
parce que le pouvoir vise une victoire
au premier tour une victoire par ko vous
le savez si en second tour quel que soit
le candidat face à alassane ouattara
votre choix se portera sur lui vous
appellerai vos militants en côte
d'ivoire a voté pour ce candidat contre
alassane ouattara le scrutin est
normalement et plus vous êtes déjà
comparé de second tour moi je suis
encore à ce qu' on puisse créer les
conditions d'une élection sans violence
d'une élection sans victimes écho à
l'issue de cette élection
le victorieux ce soit simplement la côte
d'ivoire nous aurons le temps des
blindés tout cela les candidats auront
talent et des défilés avec les candidats
avec leur jeudi le projet de société
pour convaincre les iguanes mais qu'il
met ton - mission et qui le tournoi en
mission pour coiffer et dans quelles
circonstances
je vous le répète encore madame
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
dans les circonstances pareilles c'est
le conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un
musée ce que je te parlais des
circonstances
des violences amnesty international suit
de très près ces violences évoque des
jeunes armés de gourdins de machettes
qui ont attaqué des manifestants
vous en avez certainement entendu parler
au nom de qui ces jeunes descendent dans
la rue et pourquoi pourquoi ils sèment
le chaos
je ne vais pas parler de ce que je ne
sais pas mais je vais vous citer un
exemple ici que je prenais nous sommes a
dit benoît la localité dont je suis
originaire monsieur va y aller junior
originel et guy benoit a été maintenue
par des miliciens sous le contrôle de
monsieur sy et cambon président de la
jeunesse du rhdp pâture pouvoir traîner
donc dans toute la ville des 10 de poids
il a été obligé à scander des slogans en
faveur du président ouattara
ces jeunes hommes sont connus les vidéos
circulent connu de tous
jusqu'aujourd'hui la justice terrestre
il est au contraire c'est plutôt plus
chez rick barry qui est mise en prison
pour avoir dit non à bon mois le jeune
homme à 1100 au fils chéri bas les plus
chéris balle et on a précisé charles blé
goudé on va préciser que pulchérie balle
et c'est la présidente de los angels
tentative citoyenne ivoirienne une
organisation de la société civile proche
de l'opposition
c'est vrai elle a été arrêtée et son
arrestation est jugée arbitraire par à
ses proches
nestea international d'ailleurs aussi
s'en inquiète
s'agissant des manifestations et de ces
jeunes qui descendent dans la rue les
autorités dénonce une
instrumentalisation justement de ces
jeunes par l'opposition vous qui être
être l'ancien leader des jeunes
patriotes
que répondez-vous aux autorités je vous
ai cité les indécis le jeune ministre a
mis sur mini un jeune homme arrivé loi
kg termine à toute la vie
la vidéo est là ils sont connus le
président de la république est là il est
muet pour au moins ce cas là les visages
sont cons les noms sont connus les
domiciles sont connus à vivre on y
résident
s'appelle guy benoit les noms sont là
pourquoi les autorités 70 il est que et
ses autorités de brûlure de la justice
et de l'ordre en côte d'ivoire ne puisse
pas faire un soft qui est gênant à
répondre de leurs actes a beau moi mais
ça a été tué par balles le jeune qui
marchèrent h à la meinau
il faut arrêter ce jeu là et faire en
sorte de ramener le calme en côte
d'ivoire
la politique de la rentrée pour conclure
on conclut charles blé goudé
vous n'avez rien à voir vous mais
l'opposition dans l'instrumentalisation
des jeunes qui sortent dans la rue avec
des machettes et des gourdins pour semer
le chaos
lors des manifestations vous savez quand
on le croise au sol l'eau et qu'il vous
dit que le cas il a mal à la tête
il faut qu'au loin je suis ici pour
répondre des charges liées à la crise
post électorale
j'ai subi un procès pendant des années
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui c'est que
plus jamais y voir un événement j'ai
n'ai rien à voir avec ça et je ne crois
pas que l'opposition ait à voir avec ce
qui s'est passé tous les cinq ans c'est
plutôt les manifestants ont une lecture
it est attaqué par des jeunes miliciens
proches du pouvoir
il faut arrêter ce cycle des bulles
merci à vous charles blé goudé pour
cette grande interview accordée à rtl
france
et merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
grande interview une grande interview
que vous pouvez retrouver en podcast sur
nos réseaux sociaux à très bientôt merci
de votre attention
[Musique]